it's 608 here on a monday morning you
know school is out for summer we're
helping children
and their families find ways to fill the
time so all week long here on good day
we're going to highlight local
businesses and camps they're going to
keep little ones learning
having fun and showing off their
creative side bianca holmen kicks off
today over miami
art where kids can hone their artistic
skills bianca i've been promised a mess
and i would like to see one
oh yes well i'm not going to get messy
take a look these kids they're going to
get messy we had to have them put on
ponchos
so they don't get paint all over
themselves but i'm joined here by the
owner chelsea bailey so tell us
this was born out of a love for art and
you know kind of bonding time with your
daughter
right and it's just kind of a way too
that they can actually make a nice piece
that still looks nice but then still
have fun with it too
for sure so tell us about some of the
hands-on activity i know we got this
this is like splash art right
yep we have the action art we have just
regular canvases you can paint we have
a lot of wood pieces you can paint um
really it's just a little bit of
everything and i know parents love this
because they don't have to clean up
but also you know it just is a nice
creative outlet for them
yes it is it's a very creative outlet
they get to express themselves
and really they just get to pick and do
whatever they want to do while they're
here which is
something kids don't get to do often so
they extra love it
yeah again you know there's so many
benefits for them to be able to express
themselves and just let loose look at
this one here
this is chelsea's daughter right here
she's having a lot of fun
she loves it she gets crazy with it it's
one of her favorite things is action art
but that's the joy of it they get a
creative outlet we get them off the
tablets
off the tv off the computer and into
doing something creative so john i
promised you a mess and take a look
it's a mess back to you guys in the
studio i mean it's a well-behaved
mess in fairness it is a messy i'll give
you that bianca but it's a well-behaved
mess which is good
they're having a lot of fun on a monday
well-behaved mess yeah
yes yes organized chaos yeah we'll have
to have that shown in like a museum
somewhere around town we'll have it at
the bellagio or something
good stuff bianca we'll catch up with
you a little bit later on appreciate
that always good to try and find
some local businesses that we're trying
to highlight certainly like that one
like that art studio
here on good day las vegas we're
highlighting those businesses as we try
and
help find things for families and kids
to do over the summertime tomorrow we're
going to check out a summer camp for
youngsters
who want to hone their acting skills
that will be tomorrow morning on good
day las vegas